[Music]
everything worth doing in life has risk
learn to ride a bike learn to walk when
I was a kid learning to walk I fell and
cracked my skull but I needed to learn
to walk taking a test getting married
getting a driver's license all of those
things they give you an improved
capability or an improved richness in
life but they all come with a degree of
risk that is exaggerated if the thing
that you want to do is fly a rocket ship
rocket ships are dangerous they're it's
a controlled explosion if you drew a
cartoon of a rocket what it would be
would be a bomb with six seats on the
top I mean rocket ships are crazy
dangerous on the first flight of the
space shuttle when Bob Crippen and John
Young were sitting there back in 1981
and they blasted off out of Florida now
that we go back and we look at what the
actual history of the Space Shuttle was
their odds of dying that day in the
first eight and a half minutes were one
in nine terrible odds one in nine I mean
look around you and ten people and
realized that just to try that one in
nine times they would have died they got
away with it and we learned a lot from
it but even when I flew on my first
shuttle flight on the 74th shuttle
flight we'd learned enough things we'd
improved it but the odds of dying that
day for my crew were still 1 in 38 which
is no insurance company would be happy
but it's hard to get life insurance as
an astronaut actually but but the
question you really need to ask that is
do I want to learn to walk do I want to
ride this bike do I want to get married
do I want to learn to drive a car what
risks are worth taking in my life
because even if you decide okay I'm
gonna take no risk I'm gonna stay at
home and hide under my pillow
there's still risk with that and you're
still gonna die eventually anyway so
it's kind of a measure of what was worth
doing in your life and therefore what
was worth taking a risk for once you've
got that behind you and said okay I'm
gonna be an astronaut I'm gonna fly a
rocket ship
that's a risk I'm going to take now it
changes your whole job your job is not
to be
fraid your job is not to be an
incompetent nervous passenger your job
now is to defeat the risk like when you
learn to ride a bike if you just stay as
a passenger on the bike you're never
gonna know what to do with the
handlebars and you're never gonna master
riding a bike and once you can ride a
bike you know you've got a freedom you
never had before and rocket ships are
just the same you have to decide what
risks are worth taking and then start
changing who you are learning how to
turn the handlebars so that you could
make this thing do something that
otherwise might hurt you or kill you and
then once you've got that done it can
take you to places and give you richness
in your life that you never would have
had access any other way and in my case
when you make it through that launch
when you've guided that rocket up your
the atmosphere and the engines shut off
suddenly you're in the rarest of human
experiences you're weightless and the
world is pouring by at five miles a
second and you can see across an entire
continent and and you're you're peering
into something that is brand-new for
Humanity so I think it's worth asking
yourself what risks are worth taking and
once you've decided to take them then
change who you are so that you can win
you can defeat you can master that thing
and open a door for yourself that
otherwise was just shut
[Music]